well the first thing to notice is that
you can be for markets without being
against redistribution i am nicolas be
with reason TV and today we're joined by
eric Agner he's a philosophy professor
at George Mason University and the
author of the 2007 book Hayek and
natural law and more recently he's
written an interesting article in
Politico about why Friedrich Hayek would
be in favor of centralized health care
or nationalized health care Eric thanks
for joining us pleasure you talk a
little bit about this this is of some
months old but you wrote a piece for
Politico which is interesting from a
libertarian point of view because you
actually point out that Friedrich Hayek
one of the great patron saints of
contemporary libertarianism actually was
in favor of things like nationalized
health care he would have been in favor
of mandates I think the first thing to
know about Hayek is that he was actually
for redistribution so this doesn't sound
like the sort of thing somebody like
Hayek might say you might think he had a
stroke who made a mistake at some point
in his writings but this is actually a
theme that goes back his entire career
in 1944 and wrote has served him he said
something about how he'd always been in
favor of a minimum income for all and
the same theme comes back throughout his
life and then in the constitution of
Liberty which in many ways is considered
his magnum opus he actually talks about
the you know welfare payments minimum
wage but also he signals that he'd be in
favor of some kind of universal health
care that relies on mandates talk a
little bit about how does he square that
with the idea of maximum individual
liberty well the first thing to notice
is that you can be for markets without
being against redistribution right so
for Hayek the central argument for
markets the main reason why markets work
so well has to do with a function of the
price system so Hayek emphasize how
surplus forces of supply and demand
operate in such a way that prices
reflect all sorts of information that
any individual member could not have so
and this also carries through in things
like Milton Friedman who also talked
about a guaranteed minimum
at various points and of course in the
50s popularized the idea created the
idea of school vouchers and the idea was
to create a market in education where
there was more choice and if it wasn't
the price system at least there would be
a discovery process by people choosing
among different options that's right the
important thing to know about Hayek is
that you must not interfere with the
price system unless you absolutely have
to but redistribution is consistent with
having a free-market operate and the
price system will function like it's
supposed to what from a kind of Hayekian
point of view what are the limits on
that though because Hayek certainly
recognizes that whenever government got
too large or actually in the road to
serfdom we talked about how some
planning leads to more planning there's
a seems to be a natural tendency for the
government to grow to a point where it
starts choking off market signals or or
the politics become such that people are
no longer free to act that's right and
there's a fairly bright line in Hayek's
work where he says governments are not
allowed to interfere with the price
system unless it's absolutely necessary
once government's start doing that we're
on the road to serfdom that is there's a
real possibility that we'll descend into
someplace we do not want to be but
redistribution is okay and you could
even argue that some redistribution
makes the markets work more efficiently
what how do you mean by that so the idea
is that the price system works so well
because prices contain information
that's distributed across the society
and some people are precluded from
operating in the market because they
don't have any resources the information
that they have access to won't be
reflected in prices and so some degree
of redistribution is unlimited amount of
redistribution might actually make the
prices in work more efficient now to
talk about something like Obamacare I
mean we're less than a year out from its
full implementation in January of 2014
one of the things that's striking about
it though is that it does have an
individual mandate which was very
controversial had to go all the way to
the Supreme Court before being you know
that it is as constitutional there are
all sorts of ways in which the price
system is massively distorted in
Obamacare so for instance they spread
between what insurers can charge people
over 60 versus people under 30 currently
that's capped at about five times
/ you know the average difference it's
gonna be capped at three times which
means that younger people are going to
be paying more for insurance older
people will be paying less is that kind
of violence to pricing something that
would invalidate you know health care
reform from a Hayekian perspective that
aspect of the law would be completely
out of the question from a Hayekian
perspective the idea of price floors or
price ceilings or price controls at all
would displace the function of the price
system what is consistent with a Hayek
envision I think is this idea that you
can restrict resources from people who
have more of it to people who have less
of it and that you can mandate people to
purchase health insurance Hayek does not
spend a whole lot of time talking about
this but I think we can fill in the
blanks so he's concerned about the
minimum income for all he's concerned
about everyone having access to basic
social services and he proposes mandates
essentially as a way to get around this
why would he have done that well the
ideal Hayekian system would really
involve cash transfers to the poor and
they have and these specific things that
I mean it wouldn't be food stamps it
would be here's cash buy food with it
buy cigarettes by health care whatever
you want exactly but is that way the
poor would be maximally free to spend
the money they receive this might be
politically unpalatable this might be
part of the reason why I didn't propose
it but the other thing to note about
health care is that most people can
afford it actually buy it as by giving
people money and mandating that they buy
health insurance you're not too far off
the target why are you interested in the
Hayek and how do you see him fitting
into a broader range of political
philosophy that goes beyond libertarians
so I originally came to Hayek as a
philosophy of science I was a philosophy
of science first I was interested in his
work he's on in biology and evolutionary
biology so Hayek has this theory of
group selection as an essential part of
his project I was originally interested
in criticizing that but then as I read
more and more about Hayek I realized
what an interesting and multi-faceted
figure he is and I actually ended up a
lot more interested in his work on
information and knowledge which is what
we've been talking about do you define
yourself as being on the right or the
left or had it how do you characterize
yourself
in an American context I don't really
use those categories I think they're
unhelpful I have very strong libertarian
leanings although I also see a role for
redistribution I see a role for social
services much like Hayek did do you find
Hayek at various points has been the bet
noir of people on the left and at other
times people especially on the left have
reached and said you know this is a guy
who has something really powerful to say
both to you know people on the
progressive left as well as on the
free-market right
do you see Hayek as a useful person to
Rican to kind of pull together a new
consensus that might get us past some of
the sticking points of 20th century
political philosophy absolutely he's so
much more interesting than both his
critics and he's admires sometimes let
on I get the sounds occasionally that no
one reads him very carefully because
there's so much material there and I
think you're you're absolutely right
he's offering a vision of a middle
ground he's allowing classical liberals
to say to their leftist friends that yes
we're also in favor of redistribution
there's a rule for that but there are
certain balance that we've got to stay
inside and I think that might help us
overcome some of the most vicious
divisions of contemporary American
politics well we'll leave it there we've
been talking to Eric Agner of George
Mason University he's a hike scholar his
2007 book is Hayek and natural law for
recent TV I'm Nicholas